en
parallèle à la mer la rue d'esprit
traverse un quartier résidentiel de
sainte-suzanne pratique elle débouche
sur le centre ville plus précisément sur
l'église à l'autre bout le christ en
croix une église une croix il y
aurait-il un rapport avec le nom de
cette rue
est ce que vous savez qu'ils étaient des
prêts non je ne sais pas quand je vais
pas si j'ai plus envie maintenant on
pourrait demander avec
des gens du coin comme l'était timité
habitent ici me l'avait pas de ce à quoi
eh bien le maire ancien s'appelait
monsieur des prix habiter ici des
précités port est tout
il ya un autre qui avait chapelet
châtelain le lotissement à côté appelle
lotissement de châtelain
julien florent félix desprès est né dans
le nord de la france en 1807 c'est au
grand séminaire de cambrai qu'il fait
ses études de philosophie et de
théologie il est ordonné prêtre en 1830
ce n'est qu'en 1850 que le prince louis
napoléon bonaparte le nomme à l'évêché
de saint denis la même année le papy 9
transforme la préfecture apostolique de
saint denis en diocèse
notre curé après avoir été sacré évêque
à roubaix débarque donc dans l'île en
1851 le premier réveil de la réunion a
droit à un accueil grandiose
pendant les deux années qui suivent ils
visitent son diocèse puis rentre à paris
et à rome avant de revenir toujours dans
la liesse
l'évêque s'attèle alors à la
construction d'une nouvelle cathédrale
un coot bâtiment qui pour cause de crise
économique ne verra jamais le jour et
dont le chantier laissera sa place au
futur collège juliette dodu
à sa demande les jésuites commence à
évangéliser les engagés indiens ils
uniformise également les comportements
du clergé avec rigueur
en 1857 il est envoyé à limoges par
décret son départ s'effectue dans
l'ambiance des adieux déchirants d'une
foule considérable
il finira sa carrière ecclésiastique
comme archevêque de toulouse et mourra
d'une crise cardiaque en 1895